et pour évoquer cette situation
chaotique en afghanistan le général
dominique trinquant ancien chef de la
mission militaire française à l'orée du
mont soir dominique trinquant merci de
répondre à nos questions plus de 300
afghans qui se réfugie au tadjikistan
alors que les talibans disent contrôler
près de 85% du territoire s'est avancée
des insurgés islamistes
elle est inéluctable est ce que c'est
une question de jours pour qu'il
reprenne totalement le pays
inéluctable je ne sais pas mais
prévisible très certainement si vous
voulez l'afghanistan est en guerre
depuis longtemps les américains depuis
20 ans avant les russes personne n'a
réussi vraiment à pacifier ce pays et
pour ne parler que des 20 dernières
années
les stratégies se sont succédé sans
vraiment avoir eu une adhésion complète
des afghans donc les talibans qui était
qu'ils avaient été repoussés très
initialement il ya 20 ans il avait été
battu et bien ont repris le dessus et
aujourd'hui il ya deux options les
talibans réussissent à conquérir tout le
pays
c'est une option ou bien la guerre
continue entre différentes factions en
afghanistan mais je vois difficilement
d'autres options le pentagone dit avoir
rapatrie 90% de ses trop peu idem pour
londres les afghans qui ont aidé
washington vont être a évacué par avion
par les états unis fin juillet
les rares les rats quittent le navire
mais quelles conséquences pour la
population veut non mais vous avez
raison la population est maintenant
comme
comme solution soit dans la deuxième
option je disais je signalais de
combattre contre les talibans avec des
factions soit ceux de se soumettre à la
dictature des talibans une fois qu'elle
sera installé c'est très triste pour les
populations afghanes
mais ceci illustre bien le fait qu'on ne
peut pas apporter une solution un pays
en venant de l'extérieur
la solution doit venir du pays lui-même
et il est vrai que l'afghanistan est un
pays qui est particulièrement compliquée
à pacifier de l'intérieur mais quel
avenir alors pour l'afghanistan et
quelles conséquences pour la région
est ce que des pays voisins comme le
tadjikistan comme le pakistan est ce
qu'ils peuvent être inquiétés par les
talibans ce qui va y avoir un risque
d'embrasement de la région écoutez
toutes ces régions que vous citez sont
très très proches effectivement de
l'afghanistan pour ne citer que le
pakistan la zone qu'on appelle la zone
frontalière
la zone tribale qui est avant la
frontière
exact du pakistan est une zone
extrêmement perméable avec l'afghanistan
c'est d'ailleurs là qu'on avait
découvert monsieur oussama ben laden
donc on voit bien qu'il ya une porosité
qui fait que la menace peut s'étendre
maintenant je pense que les talibans ont
une visée plus local plus visées sur
l'afghanistan et donc je pense qu'il ya
peu de chances pour que cela s'étende
au-delà de l'afghanistan en revanche la
menace qu on peut craindre c'est une
menace de dissémination du terrorisme
est-ce que les talibans vont être des
sponsors d'un certain nombre de
mouvements de terrain et c'est ça qui
nous intéresse nous pour la sécurité de
nos pays vingt ans de guerre 2000
milliards de dollars soit dix fois plus
que la première guerre mondiale
pour qui pour quoi pour rien
iliad georges beaulieu bush qui a parlé
ce matin lui qui avait envoyé un tout
tout ses troupes américaines en
afghanistan il a critiqué le retrait des
troupes américaines
oui le critiquer le retrait des troupes
américaines qui est la conséquence de la
décision qu'il a pris initialement
il faut se rappeler que lorsque nous
sommes intervenus et jeudi nous parce
que les français se sont joints très
rapidement à l'opération américaine
le but c'était de retrouver monsieur
oussama ben laden il avait été demandé
aux talibans de le livrer ils ont refusé
de le livrer et donc il ya eu un moment
à ce moment là une invasion américaine
aidée par quelques pays pour combattre
les talibans qui abritait osama ben
laden
ceux ci pouvaient être un objectif qu'on
comprenait pour les pays occidentaux
mais lorsque petit à petit la stratégie
a changé et a commencé par vouloir
installer la démocratie en afghanistan
ensuite s'occuper de la libération des
femmes en afghanistan
on voit bien qu'il ya un décalage qui
s'installe entre la réalité du pays et
les objectifs qui sont affichées par les
occidentaux
donc on n'est pas très surpris qu'au
bout de vingt ans tout ceci est échoué
vous disiez tout à l'heure tu as des
risques l'une des conséquences ça
pouvait être la dissémination du
terrorisme beaucoup d'afghans elle avait
encore un plus de 300 ils sont partis
24 g qui scandent voisin beaucoup
d'afghanistan qui tentent de fuir le
pays
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à des
milliers de déplacés
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à une
nouvelle vague migratoire vers l'europe
oui je pense qu'on peut s'attendre à une
vague migratoire pour une raison simple
depuis 20 ans le l'afghanistan a été
mêlé à l'occident les forces
occidentales qui étaient là bas ont
commencé à faire du développement ouvrir
des écoles à éduquer les jeunes femmes
etc et toutes ces personnes ne vont pas
accepter ce que les talibans vont leur
proposait donc soit ils se soumettent
soit ils s'en vont et donc c'est le
risque effectivement de voir un certain
nombre d'afghans
au delà de ce que bien sûr qui ont aidé
les forces internationales
je veux parler des interprètes de guides
etc il ya toute une partie de la
population en particulier des femmes qui
ne voudra pas rester dans un pays dans
lequel les talibans imposeront une loi
contraire à ce qu'elles ont connu depuis
20 ans merci 2 min rencontre avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général ancien chef de la
mission militaire française aux nations
unies